[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
also known as holmen was considered one
of the best or the
best large player in tekken 6.
he also uses a wide selection of
characters including mishimas
he started being active in tekken 5
using heihachi
and would compete in high level
tournaments in korea
[Music]
but needs to get out of the corner
[Music]
holmen became more popular in tekken 6.
he joined tournaments internationally
and would regularly compete in korea's
tekken crash
along with his teammates knee and tongue
[Music]
oh
in tekken tag 2 his team resurrection
with a new addition
howe would capture the trophy in tekken
busters
and they were given the chance to
compete in an international tournament
called e-stars which was held in seoul
[Music]
[Music]
korea
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
okay
after the first few years of tekken tag
2 he then became inactive
we couldn't find any more information
but there was a mention that holman quit
playing tekken to focus on his job
which is also related to gaming we also
found some info
on reddit that he still plays tekken on
steam using
claudio but once again these are not 100
accurate for sure many would love to see
him come back and compete in tekken 7
and it's interesting if he's still going
to main lars despite many considering
him as bottom tier
that's it for this episode be sure to
click like and subscribe
once again this is johnny unitas and
thank you for watching ochoto tv
[Music]
hmm
you